Qué impacto puede tener el terremoto en
estas elecciones programadas para mayo
el primer impacto es que seguramente van
a detener el plan de hacer las
elecciones en mayo originalmente estaban
planeados para el 18 de junio erdogan
había indicado que las quería realizar
en mayo pero lo más probable es que el
primer impacto es que las van a retrasar
eso es casi una certeza
si hay alguna figura ahora mismo que
pueda hacer fuerte o posicionar dogán
porque recordemos que el pasado
diciembre por ejemplo se inhabilitó al
ex alcalde de Estambul una de las que
parecía una de las principales figuras
en contra del actual mandatario
un tema creo que interesante aquí es que
la estrella política de erdogan empezó a
crecer justamente después del terremoto
de 1999 que también fue año electoral y
erdogan había sido justamente alcalde de
Estambul hasta 1998 pasando ese año hubo
un terremoto hubo elecciones Y a partir
de ese año de 1999 uno de los grandes
temas de discusión que llevaron al pues
y al crecimiento de la figura política
de erdogan fue justamente el tema de los
terremotos y de la respuesta emergencias
en este momento
a pesar de todas las críticas con
teodogan erdogan ha tenido una capacidad
muy amplia de someter a todos los
posibles rivales políticos a partir de
el intento de golpe de estado del 2016
entonces cada vez que aparece una figura
como esta como el alcalde de Estambul
siempre surge ahí algún tema que si
acusaciones de corrupción o de de que
vayan en contra del secularismo del
Estado cualquier cualquier pretexto pero
lo que hemos visto es que cada vez que
aparece una figura erdogan hasta este
momento tiene la capacidad de someterlas
ha hablado usted del buen nombre que se
ganó erdogan al llegar al poder por otro
terremoto sin embargo ahora ha sido
criticado precisamente por su lenta
respuesta A qué se debe que haya sido
tardía su visita teniendo en cuenta la
magnitud del hecho
Es un poco difícil leer Porque habría
tomado una decisión tan pues tan
desafortunada Pero uno de los temas es
que recordemos que esa zona de Turquía
ya era una es una zona de guerra
gaseante particularmente ha sido el
epicentro desde donde han salido los
movimientos bueno primero la recepción
de refugiados sirios de los 2000 en 2014
y desde entonces Y también hace dos
meses erdogan lo que estaba diciendo es
que se Estaba preparando para una una
nueva ofensiva militar Precisamente en
esa zona entonces me parece que en
términos de seguridad y ya lo han
manifestado también
en agentes de de ayuda y rescate de
otros países en términos de seguridad
también es muy muy delicada la situación
entonces creo que una de los factores
importantes para erdogan no viajar Tan
pronto a la zona es que si La amenaza
también es que
agentes de los partidos kurdos podrían
también aprovechar la la situación y yo
creo que por lo menos eso es uno de los
factores